TONIGHT, CNN OBTAINING AN
INTERNAL EMAIL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
WARNING STAFFERS TO PREPARE FOR
POSSIBLE VIOLENT CIVIL
DISTURBANCES AROUND ELECTION
DAY.
GROUND ZERO FOR THOSE GROWING
TENSIONS RIGHT NOW IS ARIZONA,
WHERE SOME VOTERS ARE LATCHING
ONTO ELECTION LIES PUSHED BY
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR, SENATE AND
SECRETARY OF STATE.
DONIE O'SULLIVAN IS OUT FRONT.
IN THE CRUCIAL SWING STATE OF
ARIZONA, REPUBLICAN NOMINEES UP
AND DOWN TO ABOUT ALLEGED WITH
NO SUBSTANTIATED EVIDENCE THAT
THE 2020 ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE KARI LAKE, THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
GOVERNOR.
>> ANYBODY WHO WAS INVOLVED IN
THAT CORRUPT, SHADY, SHODDY
ELECTION OF 2020, LOCK THEM UP.
[APPLAUSE] >> CNN SPOKE TO
VOTERS AT HER RECENT CAMPAIGN
EVENTS ABOUT THE CONFIDENCE IN
THE LOOK ACTION EVENT.
>> IT'S HARD TO TRUST ANYBODY.
>> IF WE WENT ELECTION, THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT KERI LAKE WILL
WIN.
>> WE ASKED --
CHAIRMAN BILL GATES, WHO
HAPPENS TO BE A REPUBLICAN, TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
>> I THINK EVERYONE HAS SOME
ABOUT THE EXTENT THAT THEY CAN
VERIFY THAT BALLOTS THAT WERE
MAILED OUT WERE ACTUALLY FILLED
OUT BY THE PEOPLE THEY WERE
INTENDED FOR AND RETURNED BY
THEM AND NOT FILLED OUT BY
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> ON THE ENVELOPE ITSELF, THEY
FILL OUT AN AFFIDAVIT AND SUN
AND AFTER DAVID THAT INDICATES
THAT IT WAS THEM, AND IF THAT
SIGNATURE DOES NOT MATCH THE
SIGNATURE THAT WE HAVE IT ARE
VOTER REGISTRATION, WE WILL
CALL THEM UP AND TRIED TO
CONFIRM, DID THEY ACTUALLY DO
THIS?
I THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
ELECTION OFFICIALS WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH FBI TYPE TRAINING
TO LOOK AT SIGNATURES AND TO
COMPARE THEM, RIGHT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> SO MANY EYEBALLS ARE LOOKING
AT THIS.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRUSTWORTHY, WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH THOROUGH BLACK GROUND
CHECKS THAT WE CAN PUT IN
SECURELY, KNOWING THAT OUR
ELECTIONS, BOTH SIDES, CAN HAVE
A FAIR CHANCE AT WINNING
FAIRLY.
>> SOME OF THEM, IT MAY BE THE
FIRST ELECTION, BUT A LOT OF
THEM, WE HAVE A CHECKERED,
KNOWING THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
TRUSTWORTHY.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN PARTY
WORKING TOGETHER, SO EVEN IF
YOU DO HAVE SOME SORT OF ROGUE
ACTOR, THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WATCHING THEM.
WE EVEN DO HAVE THE LIVE STREAM
CAMERAS.
THERE'S SO MANY CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN OUR SYSTEM THAT
PEOPLE JUST AREN'T AWARE OF
BECAUSE WE HAVE NEVER HAD TO GO
OUT AND ARTICULATE THAT TO
PEOPLE, BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCEPTED FOR THE MOST PART THE
RESULTS OF ELECTIONS.
>> WE GOT TO GET RID OF THOSE
MACHINES AND GO TO PAPER
BALLOTS, CHARACTER BY THE
PRECINCT COMMITTEE MEN.
>> PEOPLE VOTE ON PAPER, BUT WE
DO USE A TABULATION MACHINE AND
AGAIN, WE HAVE USED THOSE FOR
DECADES.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE MACHINES
HAVE BEEN AUDITED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
WE HAVE SHOWN TIME AND TIME
AGAIN BY MANY EXPERTS THAT ARE
MACHINES ARE NOT CONNECTED TO
THE INTERNET IN ANY WAY.
HERE'S THE REALITY, THE
MACHINES THEMSELVES ARE DOING
MORE ACCURATE JOB OF COUNTING
VOTES THEN HUMANS DO.
WHEN THE COUNT IS OVER, WHEN
THE MACHINE COUNT IS OVER, WE
DO A HAND COUNT ON US TO
CONFIRM THAT THE MACHINES ARE
OPERATING PROPERLY.
>> JUST TO BE HONEST, DO A JOB
FOR THE STATE AND PARTY, DON'T
MAKE IT PERSONAL.
>> I AGREE WITH HIM AND SO I AM
A REPUBLICAN.
HAVING SAID THAT, THIS IS A
NONPARTISAN ROLE THAT WE HAVE.
THE REFERENCE TO ME IS
PERSONAL.
I THINK ALL OF THIS HAS GOTTEN
HORRIBLY PERSONAL, AND THE
PERSONAL INSULTS TO OUR HURDLE
BACK AND FORTH ARE NOT GOOD FOR
OUR DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC BUT
FURTHER THAN THE, IT'S NOT GOOD
FOR OUR CIVILIZATION, FOR OUR
CULTURE, THAT IS WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT.
>> AARON, SPENDING SOME TIME IN
MARICOPA COUNTY ENTERS AN,
WHICH IS WHERE BILL GATES RUNS,
ELECTION OFFICIALS THERE ARE
TRYING SO HARD TO BE SO
TRANSPARENT AND TO PUT
EVERYTHING OUT THERE, BUT YOU
ALSO HEARD HIM MAKE THAT POINT
THERE ABOUT THIS DEHUMANIZATION
DEMONIZATION, NOT JUST THE
PUBLIC, SENIOR PUBLIC OFFICIALS
BUT RANK AND FILE ELECTION
WORKERS.
IT'S REALLY SAD SITUATION.
.
>> IT REALLY IS, IT'S REALLY
TERRIFYING.
THE JOHN DOE HAD TO BE
TRANSPARENT AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS, AND SOMETIMES, YOU
GET THE ANSWER TO SOMEBODY,
THEY DON'T HEAR IT.
DID NOT LISTEN TO IT.
IT IS THE FEAR.
DONNIE, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
INCREDIBLE REPORT.
I WANT TO BRING IN THE
REPUBLICAN SPEAKER OF ARIZONA'S
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, RUSTY
BOWERS.
HIS TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
JANUARY SIX COMMITTEE, RUSTY,
YOU DETAIL THEIR REFUSAL TO
OVERTURN ARIZONA'S ELECTION
RESULTS DESPITE ENORMOUS
PRESSURE THAT YOU ARE UNDER
FROM THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
OTHERS AND WHAT HE STOOD UP FOR
IT WAS THE REALITY OF A FAIR
BALL, AND THAT YOU WANTED THE
REAL ANSWER TO BE WHAT WAS OUT
THERE, YOU STOOD UP FOR THAT.
SPEAKER BOWERS, I APPRECIATE
TIME.
I THOUGHT WHAT WAS SO
INTERESTING ABOUT THAT THESE
PIECES THAT HE TALKED ABOUT,
AND THEN BILL GATES GIVES
DETAILED ANSWERS ABOUT --
EACH ONE IN SPECIFIC DETAIL.
DO YOU THINK SPEAKER THAT WILL
MAKE A DIFFERENCE TO ANY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO QUESTIONED THE
INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION.
>> AT LEAST THE PEOPLE OFFERED
A THOUGHT.
THEY HAD SOME QUESTION SOME
SPECIFIC THING TO ASK, SOME
DESIRE TO A SPECIFIC POINT WAS
COVERED AND HE COVERED THEM TO
US, I JUST SWIMSUIT COVER TO
THEM PERSONALLY, THAT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS WHO
DON'T LISTEN.
THEY GAVE UP ON THE LISTENING
THING A YEAR PLUS AGO AND IT IS
VERY FRUSTRATING.
>> IT'S FRUSTRATING AND
TERRIFYING.
YOU SAY TO YOURSELF, HOW DO YOU
BREAK THROUGH?
WOULD YOU GO TO DO THE?
HOW DO YOU TALK TO EVERY VOTER?
WILL THEY EVEN LISTEN TO WHAT
THEY DO?
IN YOUR STATE RIGHT NOW,
REPUBLICAN NOMINEES FOR
GOVERNOR, U.S. SENATE,
SECRETARY OF STATE AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ALL FOR THEM, SPEAKER
OUR TRUMP BACKED ELECTION
DENIERS.
THEY HAVE MADE QUESTIONING THE
ELECTION CENTRAL TO THEIR
CAMPAIGNS.
KARI LAKE FIRST AND FOREMOST
AMONG THEM.
SHE IS YOUR STATES REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE FOR GOVERNOR, HERE IS
WHAT SHE IS TELLING VOTERS
ABOUT NEXT WEEK'S ELECTION.
>> I AM AFRAID THAT IT IS
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE
COMPLETELY FAIR.
I WISH I COULD SIT HERE AND SAY
THAT I HAVE COMPLETE FAITH IN
THE SYSTEM.
I DON'T HAVE FAITH IN THE
SYSTEM.
>> AND SHE SAID THAT AND
SIMILAR AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT THIS?
>> ARE YOU ONLY WORRIED AT THE
FOUR OF THEM ARE ABLE TO
COMBINE AND BYPASS THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE COURT.
MY OPTIMISM IS THAT THERE ARE
CHECKS AND BALANCES, EVEN IN
THESE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE OF AUTHORITY,
WHO HAVE GREAT ALREADY, I DON'T
THINK THEIR FULL-TIME JOB WILL
BE TRYING TO UNDERMINE AN
ELECTION, BUT THERE ARE SOME,
MR. FINCHEM, FOR EXAMPLE, I
DON'T MIND SAYING, THAT'S A
GENTLEMAN THAT I WOULD REALLY
WORRY ABOUT, BUT ALL AND ALL,
WE WILL MOVE AHEAD.
THE PEOPLE, IF THEY DON'T WANT
TO HEAR RUNWAY, EXPERIENCE IS A
HARD TEACHER AND SOME PEOPLE
DON'T LEARN BY ANY OTHER WAY.
HAVING GONE THROUGH THIS
EXPERIENCE, HAVING GONE THROUGH
AND ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED, MYSELF AND
EFFECTIVELY BY DEMOCRATS,
REPUBLICANS, INDEPENDENTS,
PARTIES NOT DETERMINED, ALL
WORKING TOGETHER AT THESE
COUNTY CENTERS, THERE WOULD BE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
A CONSPIRACY DECIDES THAT HAS
BEEN PROPAGATED, AND IT JUST
ISN'T THERE.
I GAVE UP TRYING TO CONVINCE
PEOPLE, BUT I HAVE NOT GIVEN UP
TRYING TO SAY THAT THERE ARE
CHECKS, THERE IS CONCERN, WE
WILL WATCH IT.
>> I HOPE PEOPLE KNOW, IT IS
JUST SO IMPORTANT THAT YOU
SPEAK OUT, AND IT IS COURAGEOUS
THAT YOU DO SO.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE HAD
PROTESTERS, SOME ARMED, THEY
COME TO YOUR HOME DURING ALL
THIS, WHILE YOUR LATE DAUGHTER
LEG GRAVELY ILL, AND YOU ARE
GOING THROUGH PROFOUND PERSONAL
DURESS, AND THEY'RE PUTTING
INTO THAT.
YOU STILL SPEA